Manhattan da Alvin Bragg was
not answering any questions
about Trump's indictment
as he left his office. Tonight, a quiet.
But Bragg is lashing out
against House Republicans in Washington
in defense of his decision as a D.A.
to indict.
He's accusing them of collaborating
with Trump
to, quote,
vilify and denigrate the integrity
of the prosecution.
Bragg has become a target for Republicans
who have been trying to link him
to liberal billionaire
donor George Soros.
Like this, the George
Soros money machine that
spends a lot of money on the prosecutors.
Ordinary Americans
in all these different jurisdictions
that they get victimized every day
because of the reckless political agenda
that the Soros ideas bring to their job.
This is a day
that got more than $1,000,000 from Soros.
It seems to leave a nation on the edge
as we witness the Soros ification
of the criminal justice
system in this country.
Daniel Dale
is OUTFRONT now
to fact check those claims
that you just heard from Republicans.
And Daniel,
obviously, George
Soros is a long time
supporter of Democratic campaigns.
That has been true in case after case.
But what can you tell us specifically
about the relationship
between George Soros and Alvin?
Brad,
so there is no sign
of a personal relationship
between Soros and Bragg, a
Soros spokesman told me.
Soros has never once
communicated with Bragg
in any way, not in person,
not on the phone, not even on Zoom.
And Soros
did not make any donations to Bragg's
2021 election campaign.
Soros did, however, Aaron, play
an indirect role in that Brad campaign
by making donations
to a PAC, a political action committee
that supported Bragg.
Now, here are the specifics.
Soros is again
a longtime
supporter of criminal justice reform
and to candidates promoting that reform.
And his spokesman told me that Soros
and an affiliated PAC
gave $4 million between 2016 and 2022,
including 1 million in May 2021,
not specifically earmarked
in support of Bragg,
but a million in May 2021
to a racial justice PAC
called Color of Change,
which, like Soros,
also backs
reform minded candidates
around the country.
Now, Color of Change tells me
it ended up spending just over $500,000.
So not that over a million,
but just over $500,000
in support of that Brat campaign.
Now, Erin,
Bragg was outspent
by millions by his main
opponent in the Democratic primary
that he won.
And Color of Change is President
Rashad Robinson told me
it's a major overstatement.
He said a big reach to suggest
that color of change is 500 K in
spending was like the one thing
that won the election for Bragg,
who is a Harvard
Law grad, a former state chief
deputy attorney general, former
federal prosecutor,
Robinson told me
that his group was important in the race,
but merely one of many factors.
And Robinson
said, quote,
Up until last week,
we couldn't
get people to write about our PAC.
Now, all of a sudden,
we single handedly
elected the Manhattan D.A.
when he was elected.
I didn't get that credit.
Now, Robinson
also called these
Soros related attacks anti-Semitic
and he added also anti-black.
Since he said they suggest
that his experience, Black led PAC
wasn't making its own decisions
on who to support and how Aaron.
So, Daniel,
you just mentioned those accusations
of anti-Semitism.
And to that point,
I do want to show
some of how Republicans have
depicted Soros in the past
and
left wing mobs
paid to riot in the streets.
Billionaire George Soros
bankrolls the resistance and Dan Feehan.
So Soros
obviously very controversial
among Republicans.
And it also often does, Daniel,
boil down
to a very thinly veiled attack
on his religion. Yeah.
So there is a centuries
old anti-Semitic trope,
Aaron, about like sinister
Jewish puppet master somehow
orchestrating U.S.
and international events with their cash.
And attacks on Soros are often either
explicitly anti-Semitic attacks
or dog whistle attacks, invoking
that trope or in.
SIEGEL An executive
at the Anti-Defamation League,
which works to combat anti-Semitism
and told me today
that the Trump campaign's own
fundraising emails
about Barack
have, quote,
increasingly promoted
potentially problematic
language, often used as anti-Semitic
dog whistles,
including calling Soros
a, quote, puppeteer or puppet master.
And on from there.
Now, Erin,
it is certainly possible
to talk factually
and responsibly
about George Soros, his role
in the races and U.S. politics generally.
He's a major political donor,
political player in this country.
But this kind of puppet master language
just is not that responsible,
factual language. Right.
All right, Daniel, thank you very much.